Christian...
and you're looking
for a meaningful relationship
on the side.
Now you can find God's other
match for you
at AshleyMagdalene.com.
With my husband so busy running
a gay rehab center,
it's important
to me to cheat with someone
who shares my Christian values.
It's easy and free.
Start browsing millions of
profiles online
at the leading
site for Christian cheating.
♪ Catch me, Jesus,
I'm falling ♪
♪ Hear me Jesus I'm...
I'll be in
town for a few days
chairing a convention on Faith,
Flag and Family
and I'd like to meet a discreet
woman of strong moral character
who will let me try it
in the butt.
Don't ask
"What would Jesus do?"
Ask, "Who would Jesus do?"
Log on to
Ashley Magdalene today.
I live in the woods
with my wife and nine children
and I just want to meet another
guy in my same situation.
Nothing sexual.
I just want
to hang out like dudes.
Maybe measure each other's
pigs.
Ashley Magdalene.
Find God's
other match for you.